[Musique]
effectivement il ya désormais moins de
nouveaux malades par jour - de nouveaux
malades par jour que le taux de
positivité des tests c'est également
progressivement réduit on constate une
véritable diminution du nombre de
patients qui arrivent aux urgences et
qui appelle le samu enfants en rapport
avec le co vide
s'il ya des signes d'amélioration en
terme d'épidémie nous n'avons pas encore
vaincu le virus il y a encore des
malades graves il ya des malades graves
qui sont hospitalisés tous les jours
dans nos hôpitaux
je m'étonne que le ms mais c'est
peut-être ça va peut-être être le cas
n'évalue pas l'efficacité du vaccin chez
moi parce qu'on pourrait commencer déjà
maintenant à vacciner donc c'est dommage
que ça ne se fasse pas en fait nuit on
pourrait commencer déjà avec cécile
vaccins chinois et efficace et on a
beaucoup dit d'attendre le vexin
français
je pense qu'il vaut mieux rester vivant
que mourir vous avez été malade comment
ça va ça va beaucoup mieux
j'ai fini ma période d'isolement j'ai eu
quelques jours assez difficile fièvre
courbature difficultés respiratoires ça
va mieux je n'ai malheureusement
toujours pas retrouvé le goût et
l'odorat leur travail principal c'est de
lutter contre les trafics de stupéfiants
lutter contre les agressions c'est pas
de pouvoirs avec plaisir faire respecter
les règles sanitaires demandé par le
gouvernement simplement c'est nécessaire
et donc je demande à chacune et à chacun
d'avoir un comportement individuel qui
est un comportement de citoyen parce que
chaque comportement qui n'est pas
citoyen peut tuer si vous allez sur
twitter vous allez trouver un jour en
tout cas j'en ai trouvé quasiment une
centaine de messages comme cela
[Musique]
quand je vous dis que les gens ne
respectent pas le confinement la partie
dessus de chez moi est en train de faire
une soirée musique à fond avec
facilement entre 5 à 10 personnes
et comme tous les samedis soir mes
voisins font la fête comme si le coc
vide n'existait pas c'est agréable pour
personne on a tous envie d'interactions
sociales
on en a d'autant plus envie qu'on est au
moins de novembre qui est à moi qui est
un peu triste
on sait qu'il ya des dépressions
saisonnières plus vite on sort de ce
moment de confinement en ayant bien fait
mieux on se pourra se retrouver tous
ensemble
l'exemple typique de tout ça ça s'est
passé vendredi soir c'est une people
encore ses arrières nakamura la
chanteuse qui au moment de la sortie de
son album à voile a voulu faire une
soirée
sauf que voilà pas de barrière c'est
interdit les français ne supportent plus
aujourd'hui un confinement qui est un
petit peu à deux vitesses qui est un
petit peu à géométrie variable
et c'est vrai que beaucoup de français
ne mourons évidemment pas dû qu'au vide
mais mourrons de toute les conséquences
collatérales je pense évidemment aux
indépendants je pense aux artisans
qu'ils veulent c'est surtout
retravailler donc ce que je leur donne
ce que je demande au gouvernement c'est
de ne pas ajouter une nouvelle injustice
à celle de leur fermeture
c'est à dire d'ouvrir dès le 27 novembre
caen 6 la fin de la semaine on travaille
sur un protocole sanitaire pour
l'ensemble des commerces et l'ensemble
la grande distribution et j'espère qu'il
sera adopté par tout le monde on va y
travailler colligées véran avec
elisabeth bornes tous ensemble il doit
être conclue vendredi de l'opérationnel
lundi pluriel
le laboratoire américain moderna la
firme son candidat vaccin pourrait être
le plus efficace au monde
face à l'épidémie de kobe de 19 selon
les résultats partiels publiés ce matin
par l'entreprise il serait efficace à 94
5 % pour protéger de la maladie
quatre heures de là même où les ranger
dans quelle catégorie je pense que
certaines sont insultants c'est toutes
les caricatures pornographiques
je comprends que certains se sentent
insultés par cela y compris des
musulmans qui ne sont absolument pas ni
intégriste ni amis radicaux une fusée
space x en route vers la station
spatiale avec 4 astros
après son bain
trois astronautes américains et un
japonais se sont envolés cette nuit de
floride en direction de la station
spatiale internationale
la maladie est maintenant il est pas
mort pour ça ça mais elle peut avoir
juste aider manquer ce qu'était la
liberté d'expression et avoir remonté
dans il n'est pas mort pour sa samuel
bâti non il est pas mort il est mort
parce qu'il ya des terroristes des
cinglés des fous furieux killer qui qui
l'ont massacré